why does basic health have nothing to do
with what this man thinks about as a
doctor you should maybe eat less
pancakes in the morning and you should
have say I don't know how about yogurt
and fruit would that be better that
would be better you should try to lose a
little weight you should get a little
sunshine why does he never mention any
of these things he only wants you to get
boosted and boosted and he doesn't care
if you're six months old he wants you to
get vaccinated on Over My Dead Body will
my kids be getting mad so he doesn't
care if you're six months old he doesn't
care if you're 12 years old young and
healthy strong immune system out there
in school kids get sick with things it's
actually good for them he doesn't care
if you're 25 and healthy he doesn't care
if you're 70 obese he views all of those
things as exactly the same but you're
not going to believe this guys you're
not going to believe this on The View
yesterday
Whoopi actually made sense she like the
fact that
we as regular Americans would be held
accountable really irritates the hell
out of it yeah
just kidding guys I I punked you there
because that wasn't her talking about
fauci obviously she doesn't want him to
be held accountable that was her
actually talking about Sam Bachman freed
and this FTX thing I apologize for that
we punked him we did an April Fool's
joke why would we do that